- Michel Nadeau entre en
journalisme au "Devoir" en 1973.
Diplômé en sciences politiques
et titulaire d'un MBA de
l'Université Laval, l'économie
devient sa spécialité.
Très vite, il se fait connaître
de ses collègues journalistes
qui font appel à lui
à titre d'expert.
- Ou en Irlande, ou dans le sud
des États-Unis, je ne crois pas
que ce soient des endroits
où la situation politique peut
éventuellement être beaucoup
plus stable qu'elle ne l'est
au Québec ou au Canada.
- Fier nationaliste, choqué
du mépris des élites torontoises
pour l'économie du Québec,
il veut participer à son essor
et il décide de mettre
en vedette des entreprises
québécoises à succès, ses hommes
d'affaires et ses financiers,
qui formeront ce qu'on appellera
le Québec inc., et en français.
C'est ainsi qu'après 10 ans au
"Devoir", il entre à la Caisse
de dépôt et placement du Québec,
à l'invitation de son président
Jean Campeau, et de son slogan
"Faisons des Québécois un peuple
plus de propriétaires".
- ... et d'épargne
des Québécois.
- Il occupe diverses fonctions à
la haute direction de la Caisse,
dont celle de président
de CDP Capital. La recherche de
rendement maximum et de l'essor
économique du Québec ont été le
moteur de grandes transactions,
comme celle de la vente
de Provigo à Loblaws,
celle de Vidéotron à Québecor
et non à Rogers.
- On m'a confié l'important
mandat de diriger
la Caisse de dépôt.
- Sous la présidence de Jean-
Claude Scraire, la Caisse ouvre
des bureaux à l'étranger pour
l'expertise et la connaissance
de l'international.
- Aussi rassure les
investisseurs qui voient
que la politique monétaire
est bien gérée.
- Michel Nadeau quitte la Caisse
en 2002. Trois ans plus tard,
avec Yvan Allaire, il crée
l'IGOPP, l'Institut sur
la gouvernance d'organisations
privées et publiques, un
organisme unique qui offre des
recherches sur les entreprises
cotées en bourse et des conseils
de gouvernance à des entreprises
ou des organismes divers.
Ses analyses sont recherchées
et offertes avec générosités
à ses anciens collègues
journalistes.
- Michel Nadeau, bonjour.
- Bonjour, Joël.
- Ses chroniques régulières
de l'émission "Samedi et rien
d'autre" avec Joël Le Bigot
vont durer cinq ans.
Il passe en revue le parcours
du Québec en matière d'économie
depuis 60 ans.
- Les progrès qu'on a faits
durant 60 ans sont assez
extraordinaires. Prendre
notre place, c'est pour dire
aux jeunes : regardez, on est
partis de là en 1959 et ça a été
une belle aventure. 60 ans
de croissance au Québec.
- Dans ces succès,
il y a du Michel Nadeau.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Montréa